If you understand the SPMD model and the
asynchronous communication primitives,
then you're ready to write the
pseudocode for an all-to-one reduction.
So recall the problem and
our algorithmic idea.
There are p processes.
Each process has a value, and we want to
compute the global sum of these values,
leaving the result on some root process,
let's say process zero.
Our algorithmic idea was to
use a tree-based reduction.
The algorithm proceeds in about
log P rounds of communication.
The rounds iterate over bit positions.
In each round there's
a current bit position.
Processes with a one send to processes
with a zero in that bit position.
Okay so let's sketch some pseudocode.
For simplicity, let's assume
that P has a power of two, so
we'll ignore this oddball.
Let's have an outer loop
that maintains a bitmask and
we'll shift the bitmask
after every round.
The next part of the algorithm is to
have pairs of processes communicate.
The partner of any given rank differs
only in the bitmask position, so
this is an exclusive or.
Remember that senders had a one
in the current bit position, so
if you're a sender,
you need to send a message.
So if S is our local value,
then the send can just send that
value to a partner and then wait.
Once the send is complete,
the sender drops out.
Now if we're not a sender,
then we might be a receiver.
And if P is a power of two,
it will turn out we must be a receiver.
That case, we'll receive the value from
our partner and then accumulate it.
Now in this scheme, the final
result will end up on rank zero.
So for
rank zero we can print the final result.